in the centennial hills ymca is hosting  a series of programs that are dedicated  to teenagers the community center  decided to step up and offer the three  programs after the area saw a rise in  teen crime back in 2017.  now the goal is to provide a safe and  productive space for teenagers  to talk about mental health learn life  skills  and have some fun with their peers the  teens are directly involved in choosing  which topics they want to take on  come to do something that's productive  something that develops  them into tomorrow's community leaders  requires that they are at the helm of  the decision-making process from  building the framework  all the way through execution  the programs are held on the first and  third saturday of each and every month  there is a free they are  excuse me there's a fee but the ymca  says financial assistance  is readily available